matt reeves of batman is everywhere
right now the first batman solo movie in
10 years made more than 164 million
dollars at the american box office just
six days into its theatrical run and
according to box office mojo it's
already the second highest grossing film
of 2022 in the batman robert pattinson's
batman has been patrolling gotham city
streets at night for nearly two years
with little to show for it his fledgling
partnership with police lieutenant james
gordon leaves a tour at odds with the
rest of the city's power structure and
it all comes to head when the riddler
starts killing gotham politicians paul
dano's depiction of the riddler was the
first time the character appears in big
screen live-action batman content since
jim carrey played the role in 1995's
batman forever it's a distinctly
different approach daniel's character
appears much more like a villain in a
serial killer movie than carrie's loud
bombastic trickster the batman also
includes villains the penguin and
carmine falcone but perhaps the most
intriguing villain is one who makes only
an uncredited cameo appearance at the
end of the film spoilers ahead
barry kyogen of eternals and the killing
of a sacred deer fame is only credited
as unseen arkham prisoner and the batman
but when he appears imprisoned alongside
the riddler at the end of the movie
nobody could mistake him for batman's
arch nemesis the joker reeves attempts
to set up a litany of batman villains
for his burgeoning cinematic universe in
fact a deleted scene reportedly shows
batman visiting kyogen in prison to get
a profile on the riddler which has fans
wondering what the actor would be like
as the clown prince of crime while
reeves has said these villains are in
their infancy in the batman it seems
pretty clear kyogen's character will
take on the joker title in whatever
future sequel awaits robert pattinson's
batman in the meantime fans like
instagram user refinity are offering up
sample art of what kyogen's joker could
look like with green hair clown makeup
and an exaggerated red smile behind
kyogen's joker is graffiti similar to
what is seen in the batman but joker
themed kyogen's prison jumpsuit sports
the name joe although it's unclear what
reeve's joker real name is as of yet
reeves told ign that his conception of
kyogin's pre-joker stage involves a
character having a condition that makes
it impossible for him to stop smiling
making his joker title a reflection of
having lived life as a cruel joke
however the director stressed that
kyogen's inclusion is not necessarily
meant to tease the joker as a villain
for his next movie reeves told ign i
don't know that the joker would be in
the next movie but i can tell you that
here's what you're seeing is an early
days version of this character and
trouble as always is brewing in gotham
for the most part fans are liking the
potential they see in a new kind of
joker instagram user refinity said they
enjoyed the batman in the instagram post
containing their interpretation of how
kyogen's joker could look complementing
the film's portrayal of batman as a
detective and the effects posting the
visuals were stunning and most of it
looked practical which i appreciate cast
chemistry was great paul dana was
probably my favorite out of the cast
that one scene if you know you know was
exceptional reactions to the users joker
fanart which positions the right half of
pattinson's batman opposite the left
half of kyogen as the joker emphasizing
the yin-yang nature of their
relationship appear positive plenty of
users left fire emojis in the comments
of the post and the word epic was tossed
around one user wrote love this i wasn't
so sure of barry playing the joker but
when i saw it his laugh stole the show
audiences don't see much of kyogen at
all in his one scene but once his
character establishes a budding
friendship with dano's riddler that's a
mistakeable laugh signals plenty of
trouble ahead for pattinson's bruce
wayne
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one